-Welcome back. How are you
-I'm here finally on a sho
when Fred is here.
-That's true.
You have not overlapped.
-No. It's great.
-It's a nice reward for your
continued kindness to us
and continuing to come back.
-Well, this show
is kind to America.
-Oh, that's very nice
of you to say.
-The fact that you do this every
night and speak the truth...
-That's very kind of you.
-...in ways that should have you
hauled out of here
one of these days.
-Well, I'm hanging on
as long as I can.
You spoke a little truth
yesterday to moderate Dems
who you were critical of putting
too much of their faith
in the Mueller Report
being their --
him being their savior.
-Yes.
-And you wrote that "a frail old
man unable to remember things,
stumbling, refusing
to answer basic questions.
I said it in 2017,
and Mueller confirmed it today
This was a mistake."
You got a retweet from someone
who agreed with you on this.
Donald Trump retweeted you
-Yes! Yes, yes!
-Now, obviously you have
been very vocal about him.
He's been very vocal about you
How does it feel when
Donald Trump agrees with you
-But he's always -- Actually
his tweets at me are --
Actually he's afraid, I think --
He never attacks in the way --
I did get a nickname from him.
-Yeah.
-There's 200 of us.
I don't know if you're
in the club, but...
-Yeah.
-You have a nickname from him?
-He's said
"third-rate" about me.
-Third-Rate.
Third-Rate Seth.
-Well, not really --
I haven't gotten a "Seth."
I've had marbles in my mouth
That was said about me.
-I got "Sloppy Mike."
-Sloppy Mike.
-Sloppy Mike. Yeah.
[ Laughs ]
So -- Yes, he --
I think he's a little afraid
to come completely at me
because, essentially,
I'm his base.
-Right.
-I'm an angry white guy
over the age of 50,
and I have a high-school
education.
-Yeah. Right.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-So I am --
So you don't want to go at me --
You don't want to go at me
too hard.
-Right.
-So it's actually --
I so enjoy it when he does
And I tweeted him back
about the part about
we were watching
"a frail old man" yesterday.
I just said, "Donald, I wa
actually talking about you."
[ Laughter ]
-Despite everything
that happened yesterday,
you still do believe that
impeachment is the right path?
-Oh, absolutely. Absolutely.
You can't --
I don't know what's wrong
with the Democrats.
You have to, for history's sake,
for the children --
You have to say,
"This is wrong.
Presidents cannot
break the law."
[ Cheers and applause ]
And, yes, I know that
what everybody says is,
"Well, yeah,
but the Senate won't..."
The Senate doesn't impeach
Impeach is only done
by the House.
And it means that your behavio
has caused us to impeach you
and now we'll send you
to the Senate for trial.
But you don't say don't do i
because there won't be a trial
in the Senate as we know.
The Detroit Tigers do not say,
"I don't want to go to New Yor
and play the Yankees.
We're just gonna lose."
You know?
-Right.
-"Let's not do impeachment
'cause we'll lose in the Senat
and we're Democrats
and our feelings get hurt!
No! We need to fight!
We have to fight, fight, fight
You know?
[ Cheers and applause ]
We -- I mean, I'm serious.
We are -- This is serious.
Next year, next year,
people realize we could --
I think, actually, whoever
the Democratic candidate i
will get 2 million more vote
than Hillary's 3 million
that she beat him with.
I think we'll get 5 millio
next year,
and we could still lose
the electoral college.
Right.
-This is a very,
very serious thing.
And so we have to do some things
to make sure that we have
the right candidate.
We have to have
a beloved American running
not a professional politician.
We have to have somebody -
If you put up a professional
politician against Trump,
you got to have somebody
who's gonna inspire the base
The base here
of the Democratic Party --
women, people of color,
and young adults
between 18 and 35.
That's 70% of who
is gonna vote next year.
70% of the electorate
is what I just described.
So you've got to come up
with a candidate to where
when people wake up on
election morning next year
they've got to have that sense
that if you voted
in '08 or '12 for Obama --
You remember that feeling
that morning?
You couldn't wait
to get to the polls.
It's like, "I can't believ
we're going to do this today!"
Who are you
going to say that about
of the 25 that are running
right now?
When you wake up
a year from November --
"I can't wait to get to
the polls so I can vote for...
John Hickenlooper!
Or Joe Biden! Joe Biden!"
I love Joe Biden.
-Yeah. I love Joe Biden, too
-But we got to win!
-But I think a lot of --
I can understand as well -
I understand this thought
process, which is now --
Going into 2016,
I think a lot of people --
You were not
this kind of person.
You thought Trump
was going to win.
You called it state by state
I think a lot of people,
I will admit to it,
didn't think he could win.
So, now I see, and this year
I can understand that people
are like, "Just give me
the safest candidate."
Do you think that is -- Bu
you think that's a huge mistake.
-That's the worst --
No. It's the hugest mistake.
You don't want safe right now.
You've got to fight Trump
with whatever our version of -
He's a street fighter.
We need a street fighter.
That's the only way
you're gonna defeat him.
You're going up against a bully.
-Do you see street fighter
in the --
How many street fighters -
Don't name names.
But how many out of the 25
do you see as street fighters?
-Uh, two.
-Okay.
-Two of the 25 I can say.
-Come on. You can say it.
-I recall --
Well -- [ Laughs ]
Look. Bernie...
[ Cheers and applause ]